well stephanie nathan congratulations it
is now down to the two of you moving
forward into the third and final round
of this competition now in this final
round we're sending you back to your
home forges to build an iconic weapon
from history we want you to build this
sergeant hayden sword
[Music]
sergeant william hayden one of the first
english colonists in 17th century
connecticut is best known for his heroic
actions during the pequod war of 1637
after rising tensions between the
colonists and the pequod tribe erupted
payton and a group of english settlers
were sent to capture territory in modern
day mystic connecticut
during the battle with a sharp swipe of
his single edge slightly curved blade
hayden famously cut the string of a
pequod warrior's bow that was taking
direct aim at the english captain john
mason saving his life
the original historic sword is still on
display today in connecticut's
historical society museum
in hartford connecticut
so good luck we will see you in four
days
good luck
my name is nathan butcher i'm 47 years
old i'm a locksmith from bartlesville
oklahoma
bladesmithing is a hobby that i've been
doing for
33 years
but it's kind of dangerous so i
have plastic lenses in my eyes from
looking into a forge for years and years
i've had a heat stroke and
i can only count to nine
if i don't get this heat treat right i'm
gonna have to start over i need it to
stay straight
the edge sounds good feels good i like
it and it's straight
i'm happy
but i got to put it together i hope it
goes good
come about where i want to be
i think i've made a decent replica of
sgt hayden's sword i've got my sergeant
hayden sword completed i feel like i've
done the best that i can
i hope they like it
my name is stephanie iudo i'm 31 years
old i live in new york city and i'm a
part-time bladesmith
i've always had an appreciation for
knives and armor so i googled you know
new york city fleet smith and i found
fionez who is a former contestant on
fortune fire he won his round back in
season three and then his champions
round
and yeah now we're just forging buddies
and i'm happy to keep making new knives
my blade's the right length curve is the
right depth i'm feeling good and i'm
ready to quench
this is the moment of truth
just like glass successful quench i am
feeling good i am feeling tired but good
i've got my mild steel bar in the forge
bring me up to temp once it's at the
right temperature i'm gonna be pressing
it down trying to turn a long tube into
a short pancake i'm a little behind
where i'd like to be barely made a den
spent a couple of hours working on my
guard but it isn't doing what i it to do
i've gotta scrap this and start fresh
i gotta change now or the whole day is
gonna be sunk
that might work
okay
it's the end of the day looking at my
guard it's a little fugly at the moment
but there's nothing tlc can't fix let's
do it slow and steady
don't want to break anything all right
hello boys i am ready to show my friends
theo and justin to former forge and fire
contestants
well that's looking deadly very proud of
you that looks great thank you thank you
i'm just excited to see the judges use
it
please smith's welcome to the keel test
to find out how lethal your weapons are
i'm gonna take your weapons deliver some
lethal blows on this ballistics dummy
stephanie you're up first you ready for
this go have your fun
[Music]
all right stephanie let's talk about
your sword here your edge is
sharp i mean that's one of the cleanest
decapitations i've done with a sword
overall your weapon
it will kill thank you
right nathan are you ready it's your
turn sir you bet
[Music]
[Music]
all right nathan let's talk about your
sword here
those are very deep cuts
every swing penetrate the deep every
thrust went all the way through
your weapon sir
it will kill
thank you
[Music]
all right bladesmiths and you know what
time it is it's time for the strength
test
to test the strength and durability of
your blades i'll be attacking our wooden
palisades here stephanie you're up first
you ready oh yeah yeah all right
all right so stephanie in the test your
blade held up really well there's a one
small
chip it took and then maybe a little bit
of a glinting spot here but it's still
sharp we get back to here your tang
kind of kicks this way and then sort of
curves back this way what that does is
every time i hit it kind of rides
forward into that guard didn't really
hurt my knuckle but over time it's going
to be an issue but everything's tight it
held up really well in this test good
job thank you
all right nathan you're up you ready you
bet
so
so nathan really nicely done i ran my
fingernail down that blade and i cannot
feel any deformation
any knicks nothing so it's pristine your
handle shape comfortable it's got that
nice flare to it
the guard's out of my way so i'm not
hitting it nicely done good sword thank
you
all right bladesmiths this is the
sharpest test the fish slice
now a sharp edge should be able to cut
all the way through this fish and that's
what i'd like to see
stephanie here first you ready for this
go do your thing
[Music]
all right stephanie let's talk about
your weapon here when cutting through
the salmon no issues at all it cut all
the way through now when it got to the
grouper which is a scalier and thicker
fish you went more than half overall it
will cut thank you
all right nathan your turns are you
ready you bet
so
all right nathan let's talk about your
weapon here your edge when cutting
through the salmon no resistance easy
cuts on the grouper you cut in more than
half overall your weapon
it will cut thank you
well placements in this third round we
asked you to go back to your home
fortunes for four days and come back
with strong sharp sergeant hayden sores
and you both did it now in this
competition only one of you can go home
the champion and our judges have talked
it through and they've made a decision
today's fortune fire champion is
[Music]
nathan congratulations man now stephanie
unfortunately your blade did not make
the cut i'm gonna have to ask you to
please step off the forge floor
this has been a crazy journey
i'm very proud of my work but coming so
close that you can almost taste it i
definitely want to come back and give it
one more go to see if i can be the
fortune fire champion
well nathan you know what that means man
you are the forge of fire champion and
you just got yourself a check for ten
thousand dollars congratulations i
cannot believe i won i know what
happened it doesn't quite seem real
how do you feel
i have no idea
making this weapon i put everything i
had into it trying to make something
nice and i'm overwhelmed i cannot
believe i won i'm nathan butcher i'm the
forged and fire champion
you